dure semaine sur le thème de la
pornographie nous nous intéressons au
fonctionnement et aux pratiques de
l'industrie pornographique aux
conditions de tournage ou représentation
des femmes et des sexualités véhicules
et ainsi qu'à l'accès de plus en plus
précoce des mineurs au contenu pour
pornographiques et ses conséquences
notamment en matière d'éducation à la
sexualité ce dernier point est l'objet
de notre table ronde aujourd'hui
j'espère que l'image qui a disparu à
l'écran fait pas que nos collègues ont
disparu de l'audition
c'est bon on est toujours à part dont
j'ai averti
de toute façon c'est la pornographie
voilà nous sommes donc de plus j'arrive
voilà nous sommes quatre sénatrice
rapporteur pour mener ses travaux
alexandra burke you fontan laurence
cohen qui est à mes côtés et laurence
rossignol qui va nous rejoindre pour la
bonne information de toutes et tous je
précise que cette réunion fait l'objet
d'un enregistrement vidéo
accessible sur le site internet du sénat
en direct puis en vod nous avons le
plaisir d'auditionner aujourd'hui en
visioconférence ovidie auteur de
plusieurs ouvrages sur la sexualité et
sur la pornographie
réalisatrice de documentaires et plus
récemment co auteur d'une série animée
diffusée sur le site d'arte et intitulé
libre ayant pour vocation d'aider les
jeunes à s'affranchir des dictats
sexuelle parmi vos récents travaux je
souhaite mentionné tout particulièrement
votre livre publié en 2010 8 intitulé à
un clic du pire la protection des
mineurs à l'épreuve d'internet qui
traite de la massification des contenus
pornographique en ligne accessible
gratuitement sans restriction d'âge et
sans contrôle quant à la possible
violence des contenus diffusés je
mentionnerai également votre
documentaire diffusé en 2010 est
intitulé pornocratie les nouvelles
multinationales du sexe qui constitue le
résultat d'une enquête de plusieurs
années sur l'économie souterraine de la
pornographie j'ai visuel et se
visualiser ce ce reportage ce week-end
et c'était assez édifiant édifiant et
effrayant à la fois
dans votre livre de 2018 vous estimer
qu'en dix ans l'humanité a regardé
l'équivalent de 1,2 million d'années de
vidéos pornographiques et que si l'on
additionne le nombre de vidéos
visionnées sur les principaux sites
mondiaux de streaming de vidéos pornos
on atteint le chiffre ahurissant de 350
milliards de vidéos visionnées par an en
effet avec l'avènement de plateformes
numériques appelés tubes proposant des
dizaines de milliers de vidéos
pornographiques en ligne en un seul clic
et gratuitement la consommation de
pornographie est devenue massive les
sites pornographiques affiche en france
une audience mensuelle estimé à 19
millions de visiteurs uniques soit un
tiers des internautes français en outre
80 % des jeunes de moins de 18 ans ont
déjà vu des contenus pornographiques
vous indiquez d'ailleurs dans votre
livre que depuis la démocratisation du
smartphone l'âge moyen de la découverte
des premières images pornographiques ed
neuf ans
ce visionnage peut être délibéré par
l'accès à des sites pornographiques
ainsi selon une enquête ifop de 2010 est
pourtant sur des adolescents de 15 à 17
ans 63 % des garçons et 37 % des filles
de cette classe d'âge ont déjà surfé sur
un tel site et 10 % des garçons le font
au moins une fois par semaine
le visionnage de contenus
pornographiques peut également être
involontaire ou subi à l'occasion de
recherche internet du téléchargement
d'un film ou d'un dessin animé de
discussion sur des réseaux sociaux à 12
ans près d'un enfant sur trois a déjà
été exposé à des images pornographiques
outre la question de la protection des
mineurs les graves dérives dans le
milieu porno français dont la presse
s'est récemment faite l'écho amène notre
délégation à s'interroger sur les
conditions dans lesquelles se déroulent
les tournages nous avons notamment
auditionner des associations féministes
qui considère que ces tournages relève
de la prostitution filmé et du
proxénétisme
si nous avons souhaité vous entendre
aujourd'hui c'est pour que vous partagez
avec nous votre expertise et votre
connaissance de ce milieu vous pourrez
notamment nous éclairer sur les
mutations de l'industrie de la
pornographie ces moyens de diffusion ils
sont nuls tra accessibilité son modèle
économique l'évolution des contenus des
contenus vers des pratiques plus
extrêmes et violente mais aussi la
paupérisation du secteur qui touche plus
particulièrement les actrices et les
acteurs avez vous une estimation du
nombre et du poids économique des
tournages qui se font encore en france
et du nombre de personnes qui exercent
dans ce secteur il est il ressort en
effet de nos précédentes éditions
qu'aujourd'hui les tournages ont lieu
majoritairement dans des pays comme la
hongrie ou la république tchèque sans
aucun encadrement
l'affluence de la pornographie alors
pardon
l'influencent de la pornographie sur les
pratiques sexuelles notamment celle des
plus jeunes rapport au corps
construction de l'imaginaire sexuelle
diktat sexuelle diffusion de la culture
du viol la question de la protection des
mineurs aussi à l'heure de la gratuité
de la massification des contenus pornos
accessible en ligne pourquoi est-il
quasiment impossible aujourd'hui de
faire appliquer la loi française qui
interdit l'accès des mineurs aux
contenus pornographique en ligne enfin
les mesures qui permettrait d'encadrer
les pratiques à l'oeuvre dans le milieu
de la pornographie mesures sanitaires
droit à l'image charte de déontologie et
respect du consentement interdiction de
pratiques extrêmes et poursuites en cas
de pratiques relevant manifestation
manifestement droit pénal violent
incitation à l'as à l'inceste à la haine
raciale ou à l'homophobie ovidie je vous
laisse sans plus tarder la parole et
bien entendu les rapporteurs qui sont à
mes côtés à la fois laurence rossignol
et laurence cohen qui souhaiteront
intervenir peut être
immédiatement après votre intervention
et les collègues qui sont présents avec
nous soit en visio soit en séance dans
la salle rené monory je vous souhaite la
bienvenue madame et jousse aide
immédiatement la parole merci à vous
d'être parmi nous
bonjour merci merci beaucoup pour pour
cette introduction
je peux par rapport au sujet qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui je voudrais aussi
que je suis membre du comité d'experts
jeune public de l'art comme anciennement
csa depuis deux ans et a priori pour
encore des deux les deux années les deux
années à venir est également je voudrais
mentionner une action prévention que
j'ai mené de 2018 à 2020 sur département
de la charente en collaboration avec la
délégation départementale aux droits des
femmes qui était une action prévention
dans les collèges et les lycées et qui
portait sur évidemment de l'exposition
précoce aux images pour les images
pornographiques mais aussi plus
généralement la question de
sexualité au pluriel et numérique en
gros ce que l'outil soit les outils
numériques ont changé dans notre rapport
au corps et dans notre façon de
découvrir de découvrir d'autres et ses
deux années de d'action médiation avait
donné dieu un documentaire que qui a
encore en accès libre 1 par ailleurs sur
le site de france culture
est un documentaire de quatre heures
c'est que l'éducation sexuelle des
enfants d'internet on voit là où je
raconte c'est ces quatre années de
d'action de ces deux années pardon d'une
taxation de prévention
et puis je le mentionne aussi alors vous
allez dire d'habitude je fais tout pour
pas de mentionner mais là cette fois ci
je le mentionne quand même parce que ça
me semble important j'ai été moi même
actrice de 1999 à 2002 2003 donc certain
moment où cette industrie n'avait
strictement rien à voir puisque manger
et d'inactifs de bhs ce qui ne nous
rajeunit pas et c'était bien avant
internet néanmoins je le précise quand
même en propre au jeu en avant propos
parce que c'est pour vous dire je suis
pas mu par une quelconque idéologie
moral voilà tout ce que j'allais dire
aujourd'hui je suis pas dans la
rédemption et je ne suis pas là pour
servir on ne sait pas un loup qui
conservateurs ou que sais-je donc voilà
c'est une expérience que j'ai vécue dans
mon corps certes il ya 20 ans mais j'ai
quand même vécu dans mon corps avec ses
hauts et ses bas ce qui a pas les débats
il ya eu des hauts mais il n'y a pas eu
l'idée ou il ya eu débat mais voilà
c'est une expérience que je connais dans
mon corps même si encore une fois ce
média a beaucoup changé
donc aujourd'hui je vais surtout parler
d'eux c'est ce qui a évolué dans la mode
de diffusion de ces contenus là entre
autres avec l'arrivée des tul c'est
surtout des tubes dont je vais parler
puisque c'était ça le l'objet d'une
investigation de ces deux années
d'investigation avec pornocratie
et éventuellement de pas de l'impact sur
sur les jeunes impact ou pas d'ailleurs
sur ce que ça change vraiment dans le
rapport au corps dans leur approche des
sexualités
je vous avouerai que c'est pas fait je
n'ai pas préparé de communication en
tant que tel parce que j'étais pas chez
moi ces derniers temps mais surtout je
dois vous avouer alors vous remercie
vous ne m'écoutez aujourd'hui néanmoins
je dois vous avouer que j'ai trouvé un
grand découragement alors vous allez
dire que c'est pas de bol foot mais je
publie quand même c'est souvent un
immense découragement parce que parfois
en fait ça fait des années que je répète
la même chose finalement et sans rien
voir bouger
pour tous tes impôts femmes toutes les
raisons qu'on va évoquer après qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas à bloquer
ces sites on l'abordera après quelques
elles sont qu'elles sont des obstacles
qu'est ce qui fait que ça n'avance
toujours pas mais j'ai vraiment cette
sensation d'être auditionnés chaque
année donc par par divers ministres j'ai
été auditionnée par divers ministres
j'ai été auditionnée même par madame
maquereau en personne à sa demande par
par des commissions de l'assemblée
nationale par madame mercier l'année
dernière ici et j'ai cette sensation que
que sanogo samedi spa j'ai l'impression
d'être un disque d'un disque rayé donc
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je me suis
fait pour ma santé mentale je me suis
fait l'économie de préparer une
communication en tant que tel néanmoins
je répondrais évidemment à toutes vos
questions de mort si j'en suis capable
parce que ma limite aussi et c'est que
je crains c'est comme vous l'imaginez
c'est pas sorti sans peine il ya eu
quelques intimidations derrière vous
imaginez bien que ça ça change et un
certain nombre de choses dans la vie
donc je n'ai plus beaucoup de contacts
avec cette industrie là j'ai quelques
contacts avec quelques actrices encore
par twitter ou par les réseaux sociaux
mais globalement
j'ai pu vraiment beaucoup de contacts et
pendant grassi est sorti il ya déjà cinq
ans et vous savez que tout avance à la
vitesse de l'éclair dans ce milieu c'est
à dire cinq ans et c'est plus les mêmes
acteurs c'est tous les mêmes actrices et
même plus même les modes les mêmes modes
de diffusion c'est même plus le même et
même plus les mêmes producteurs sur
quelques-uns donc ça c'est un métier qui
évolue très vite donc je me limiterai
vraiment à ce que je connais et que je
continue à suivre de loin c'est à dire
ces grandes multinationales du set du
sexe qui détiennent les sites les plus
lus et les plus puissants au monde les
youtube du porno dont qui sont ceux que
que vous connaissez du port de port neuf
etc enfin surtout pour 9000 et websense
terre donc je propose qu'on parle qu'on
parle de ça aujourd'hui et qu'on se pose
la question de qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire et et pourquoi pourquoi ça
n'avance pas parce que vous êtes au
courant que c'est si clermont été mis en
demeure
récemment
parce qu'ils ne respectent pas la
réglementation française en matière de
diffusion la réglementation française je
vais l'a rappelé vraiment très
brièvement il ya un article de loi qui
est l'article
227-24 du code pénal qui interdit de
laisser à disposition des mineurs des
contenus pornographiques sous peine de
trois ans d'emprisonnement ou 75000
euros d'amendé qui ne semble donc ça
veut dire que concrètement un kiosquier
il peut pas vendre un magazine porno un
mineur et trois ans d'emprisonnement et
de 15000 euros d'amendé français bien
qu'aujourd'hui modes de consommation du
porno joe clark a parlé je ne sais pas
ça les jeunes gens consomment à partir
du moment où ils ont un téléphone dans
les mains
puisque ces sites proposent des millions
de vidéos en accès libre et gratuit
en un seul clic sans justifier de quoi
que ce soit nous delage centre sont
rentrés de kindu manquez rien du tout
donc en fait il sait là c'est à
disposition c'est très visible c'est
très présent ces cycles figure parmi les
dix sites les plus fréquentés au monde
je dire ça style à ses dires ces styles
à bourg par avance un peu c'est un peu
féminine et julia on n'est pas loin des
chiffres de fréquentation de twitter et
de wikipédia non vraiment ça fait partie
des sites les plus gros monde ils sont
là et ils sont donc accessibles en un
clic ou deux à partir du téléphone et on
sait que l'âge du premier portable il ne
cesse de descendre en fait il ne cesse
de diminuer donc
avant c'était fabre c'est l'impression
que cet égard milan mais globalement en
fait les ja non c'est leur premier
portable au moment où ils arrivent au
collège pour des questions pratiques
parce qu'on a besoin de les contacter
parce que ils vont rentrer tout seul du
collège parce qu'il passe le mercredi
après-midi tout seul et c'est donc c'est
bien normal les parents gordon un
portable pouvoirs en restant contacté et
on va pas plat mais les parents pour ça
parce que c'est une petite musique on
entend beaucoup aux 6-11 ans c'est la
faute des parents si les jeunes
regardent du porno n'ont cessé la coop
du porno si les jeunes regardent du
porno à la faute des parents en tout cas
c'est la faux pas du porno mais de ses
plateformes de diffusion en tout cas
donc cet âge il ne cesse de diminuer ya
plus en plus de gamins qui ont des des
portables en cm1 cm2 donc pas partir du
moment où ils ont un portable il faut
quand même
il faut il faut se rendre à l'évidence
dans les mois qui suivront si c'est pas
les jours dans les mois qui suivront le
moment on va leur mettre ce smartphone
ce smartphone avant c'était des contres
katusha n'a maintenant c'est quand même
long des smartphones des plus jeune âge
donc à partir mans ils ont un smartphone
qu'ils ont accès à ces sites là
donc c'est moi ce que je trouve étonnant
c'est que ces sites là il existe depuis
2006 2007 la création de youporn c'est
août 2006 pornhub c'est 2007 ils ne sont
qu'une vidéo xhamster c'est la même
année c'est 2007 où que ça fait quand
même 15 ans a fait une quinzaine
d'années en fait que ces sites existent
ça fait une quinzaine d'années que on
sait qu'ils ne respectent pas la loi
française et l'article 227-24 du code
pénal bon vous savez qu'il ya eu 7
cet article de loi sur mes disques
renner
dans l'année dernière
utilisé en groupe de 10 km heure n'était
pas suffisant indique alors vous savez
c'est oui j'ai 18 ans je clique sur
entrer et c'est donc là maintenant la
loi dit que ce n'est plus suffisant de
mettre juste un disclaimer sur la
première page de dos d'un sit in au
graphique il faut mettre un autre
dispositif de contrôle de l'âge ou de
l'identité
mais bon pour le moment en tout cas tout
ça c'est pas c'est pas vraiment mis en
place il ya eu des mises en demeure mais
je pense qu'ils sont en fait et donc ça
fait quinze ans que ces sites et
agissent en toute impunité et que
personne ne fait rien tout le monde s'en
plaint on constate quand même cet âge de
l'accès au porno qui ne cesse de
diminuer
on commence à en voir des effets aussi
est ce parce que c'est ça qui est qui et
qui m'étonne se passera alors j'essaie
de comprendre qu il se passait rien
c'est pascal pour plusieurs raisons moi
ce que j'ai observé dans les différentes
réunions vous disais j'ai été
auditionnée aux moult fois et dans ce
que j'ai pu observer c'est qu'elle est
quand même un les fournisseurs d'accès
qui traînait des pieds c'était beaucoup
ça c'était pas forcément les sites
pornos battant qu'ils ont le droit afin
qu'ils ont pourtant aux personnes les en
empêche physiquement mais
mes dents par exemple on aurait pu avoir
des velléités de recul on aurait pu
vouloir par exemple les jets ont bloqué
ce quelque chose qui aurait été que de
l'envisageable aujourd'hui je sais pas
s'il ya un site qui publie des contenus
racistes ou que sais-je en tout cas voir
la loi on va pouvoir le coq est bon là
ces sites là on n'a jamais songé ne
serait-ce qu'à deux femmes ou une espèce
de saint fons m'bolhi quand c'est bloqué
quelques jours comme on fait pour
exclure une personne sur les réseaux
sociaux quand quand la personne tient
des propos complètement inapproprié il y
aurait pu y avoir quelque chose de cet
ordre là non ça fait 15 ans en fait
qu'il n'y a absolument aucune sanction
dont il continue à diffuser à rester des
robinets a porno finalement puisque rien
ne les en empêche donc qu'est-ce qui
fait que ben voilà on s'oppose à toute
forme de sanction audio blocage bien il
y a avant tous les fournisseurs d'accès
qui s'y refusait voilà c'est ce que j'ai
pu observer
alors ce discours là il évolue une fois
au cours de ces cinq dernières années
par exemple j'ai vu que tous les
fournisseurs d'accès n'était plus
forcément raccords sur sur sur ce disque
dur sur ce discours là y'en a qui était
qui ont signé la fameuse charte
c'était quoi il ya deux ans à peu près
et qui éventuellement
était prêt à collaborer sur ces
questions là mais seulement si tous les
autres fournisseurs d'accès collaborer
on sait bien que tous les fournisseurs
d'accès sont pas d'accord enfin voilà
donc pourquoi ça n'avance pas bon pour
ça aussi parce qu'il faut bien le dire
je crois que l'état français est bien
peu puissant face à ça en fait on s'est
toutes les discussions peut avoir autour
des gars femme est en fait d'une façon
générale c'est que ont finalement on a
très peu de points on a vraiment très
peu de poids et ça c'est ça a été une de
mes grandes désillusions je dois le dire
ces dernières années si je pensais que
on avait plus de poids que ça ait en
fait visiblement n'ont
donc
donc voyons aussi ce que ça va donner en
toutes ces mises en demeure mais moi
personnellement j'en attends j'en
attends vraiment pas grand chose alors
ce que j'ai pu observer ensuite sur sur
le terrain durant ces deux années de
d'action médiation d'action prévention
sur département de la charente c'est que
déjà les jeunes que je rencontre a été
extrêmement lucide et extrêmement
conscient de tout ça
extrêmement déçu aussi des quelques
rares interventions qu'ils avaient pu
avoir durant les heures d'éducation à la
vie sexuelle et affective ou même
certaines interventions en matière de
justement de prévention entre les images
pornographiques etc oui disent eux-mêmes
que ils ne se sentaient pas concernés ou
que c'était des discours un peu plus de
pabbi liaison du type tu t'es vu quand
t'as bu forme là c'était un peu les tu
t'es vu quand t'as bu du porno c'est à
dire le porno c'est pas la réalité le
porno c'est passage en cuisine c'est pas
bien de regarder du porno
ils ne se sentent absolument pas
concerné par ça il écoutait en général
un petit peu
cheap ugg oncle est un petit peu blasé
mais on voit là c'est en tout cas c'est
un échec ce type de discours là auprès
d'eux c'est un échec ça que nous on
avait monté une action médiation d
amener à à produire leurs propres
contenus leurs propres malle pédagogique
finalement autour des questions de
pornographie autour des questions de
sexualité donc finalement c'était eux
qui créent ces outils là et ça a donné
ça donnait de choix de résultats on a
fait des courts métrages on en avait
présenté un lit avait même conçu à
l'époque de la visite de jacques toubon
qui étaient venus voir le court métrage
qu'ils avaient réalisés et enfin voila
c'était c'était plutôt un succès cette
affaire mais là je vous parle d'une
poignée d'élèves sur le département de
la charente évidemment que qu'il
faudrait mettre en place ce type
d'action / sur le reste sur le réseau la
france n'est en tout cas pas ce que ce
que j'ai constaté c'est que ils avaient
tous mis en place des stratégies
d'autodéfense numérique garçons comme si
c'est à dire il se rendait le problème
en fait j'ai vraiment pris conscience
avec eux c'est que le problème allait
bien au-delà des plates formes brno
j'enterre les plateformes porno moins
c'est mon combat il s'est presque un
combat d'hier c'est à dire que eux ils
ont accès à ces images là pas forcément
nécessairement par les plateformes port
nommés mais par les réseaux sociaux et
même par par snatch hâte par par plein
de par plein de trucs comme ça en fait
par les réseaux sociaux et ils ont donc
appris à mettre en place des stratégies
d'autodéfense numérique dans le sens
mais ça arrive a repéré par exemple des
groupes un peu obscur des comportements
un peu anormaux mais des plus jeunes
agents même ils m'ont même rapporté par
exemple que sûr que quand il était petit
donc ce qu'ils appellent petit c'est
enfin clymer début collège il aller sur
des sites de jeux par exemple le genre
habiller la reine des neiges et que
c'était là qu'apparaissait qu'apparaisse
et les pop up des pop-up porno ou des
liens pour aller visionner des images
pornos donc
ils m'ont rapporté sa mort à porto il me
rapportait aussi que quand il allait sur
des sites un peu innocent comme movistar
planète qui pousse tabliers des poupées
il était régulièrement abordée par par
des comptes un peu obscur qui leur cause
est vraiment beaucoup de questions etc
ça a donc eu en fait depuis qu'ils sont
petits depuis qu'ils ont 3 8 9 ans il
arrive à opérer les prédateurs du net il
arrive à repérer les pièges où on empile
leur faire cliquer sur sur des liens qui
les emmène vers vers des sites pornos en
fait ce qui est ce qui est fou c'est que
c'est que finalement
c'est finalement vers eux qu'il faut se
tourner pour trouver des solutions parce
que ils y sont confrontés de l'extérieur
je vous disais ces sites là il existe
depuis 2006 2007 depuis 15 ans c'est une
génération laisse pas loin quoi en fait
c'est ces îles sont ils sont les sons en
seconde là maintenant où ils sont en
premières enfin ils sont au lycée ils
ont grandi ils ont retiré bien même on a
même qui je vois parmi les étudiants
mais étudiante qui sont donc des jeunes
adultes qui ont grandi avec avec sa donc
leur dire le mal il est déjà fait en
fait ils ont déjà eu accès à tout ça
qu'on peut peut-être faire c'est essayer
de faire en sorte que que les autres
générations qui arrivent ne subissent
pas les choses mais on ne m'a déjà être
sept générations cobayes sept
générations cobayes elle existe là
maintenant elle rentre dans la sexualité
maintenant elle rend dans la sexualité
en ayant été biberonné au porno en même
temps elle rentre dans la sexualité en
étant conscientiser autour des notions
de consentement et c'est parce qu'il
rend dans la sexualité mais juste après
nous tous finalement ceux qui sont au
lycée maintenant il est et il était au
collège au moment où moment d'octobre
2010 est au collège ou à la fin de
l'école où il importe donc il y rentre
dans la sexualité maintenant avec ces
deux visions c'est à dire d'un côté le
leader exposition des images pornos et
d'un autre côté ils savent ce que c'est
que le consentement ils sont comment
dire très conscientisé autour des
notions de harcèlement des notions anglo
saxon de type slot shaming man planning
etc c'est d'ailleurs intéressant qu'on
n'est pratiquement pas les équipements
dans la langue française tout ce qui est
sport mon prono divulgation ils sont
beaucoup plus au point que nous là
dessus ils ont bien intégré il commence
à bien intégrer l'idée que la victime
c'est bien la personne qui est filmé à
son insu c'est
et que la honte doit changer de camp et
que la honte c'est plutôt du côté des
harceleurs dans tout ça il ya quelque
chose qui est vachement énormément
évolué sur les questions de sexisme le
racisme d'écologie et ça semble beaucoup
plus confortable ils sont ils sont
tiraillés entre les deux et mais
évidemment évidemment que
tout cela a forcément un impact sur
leurs rapports au corps sur la façon
dont il voit sur la façon dont ils se
rencontrent sur même le même leurs
pratiques de quand même de leur pratique
d'épilation ça passe aussi par la part
on constate alors certaines études il
faut toujours prendre avec des pincettes
mais on constate quand même qu'il ya une
augmentation
des pratiques qui autrefois était plutôt
catégoriser sadomasochisme donc bdsm
donc entre adultes consentants tillon
des codes et qui ont des contrats fin
des contrats je dire des contrats de
consentement quoi
que c'est qu'il ya eu une banalisation
d'un certain nombre de pratiques un peu
sans fil est comme ça c'est à dire sans
avoir tout le folklore autour et tout
toute cette notion de deux contrats
entre entre personnes consentantes mais
il ya certaines études voilà qui ont
rapporté effectivement que en gros on
copie on cotise ce qu'on voit à l'écran
donc il ce qu'on voit à l'écran c'est
pas toujours
c'est pas toujours très réjouissant
c'est pas toujours très glorieux c'est
parfois même assez violent pas toujours
mais parfois ça les a c'est où ça va ça
va être très stéréotypé et il va y avoir
une reproduction d'un certain nombre de
pratiques de type étranglement
vomissements gifle etc etc donc oui bien
sûr bien sûr que ça que ça a un impact
et d'un autre côté ce que je constate
quand même encore une fois c'est qu'ils
sont ils sont quand même très
conscientisé moi j'ai vraiment foi en
cette génération là parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont vraiment très
lucide sur sur toute cette question
surtout cette question a maintenant être
lucide pas dire ça nous influencent pas
et ça veut pas dire encore une fois
parce que même nous adultes je pense que
ou forcément il ya une imprégnation
directe ou indirecte des codes du porno
c'est à dire même nous adultes même si
on en regarde qu on en regarde pas il ya
une imprégnation de ces codes là qui
sont disséminés dans l'ensemble de notre
société et qu'on retrouve dans tout
notre environnement et médiatique et
culturel dans la pub dans le jeu vidéo
dans le cinéma dans les séries dans les
abribus
les codes du porno ils sont là
maintenant il faut absolument partout
donc ça veut dire que même quand on ne
regarde pas eh ben on va quand même
quand on a entre 18 et 25 ans est
intégralement utilisé la norme et c'est
donc oui bien sûr que ça a un impact
que cela a des conséquences puisque
encore une fois même sur nous en tant
qu'adulte ça en a et c'est pas parce que
on connaît la source du problème ou la
source de notre aliénation qu'on est
capable de s'en débarrasser comme ça ce
que je veux dire c'est par exemple on
peut nous adultes ou même ado avoir
conscience que
voilà il ya une volonté par exemple
voulons dire qu'on contrôle du corps des
femmes à travers les régimes ou que
sais-je et par malgré tout même si on va
connaître tous ces mécanismes là on va
quand même faire son petit régiment du
printemps même si on se dit oh là là ce
débile mais toute cette volonté de
contrôle du corps des femmes c'est
débile etc on va quand même projet le
temps mais là c'est la même chose toutes
les images qui sont autour de nous ont
forcément une influence sur notre
intimité et sur notre sexualité donc 6 a
une influence sur nous adultes ça en a
forcément une sur eux qui sont en train
de rentrer dans ma sexualité je les dis
que j'allais j'avais pas faire de
communication et que je propose à un
dialogue et je suis en train de partir
tout seul donc ce que je vous propose
éventuellement c'est si vous avez des
des points sur lesquels vous souhaitez
qu'on revienne aux qu'on développe je
m'efforcerai d'y répondre ou
bien merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation assez lucide et à la fois
négatif finalement puisque on se dit que
depuis 15 ans tout ça existe peut-être
qu'on n'a pas mesuré non plus l'impact
il ya eu en 15 ans des réactions les
violences faites aux femmes ne sont pas
apparus non plus que récemment elles ne
sont apparus que récemment donc c'est
vrai que pour le grand public c'est des
sujets qui n'étaient pas forcément des
sujets qui étaient sur le devant de la
scène et si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
donc
la difficulté vous l'avait pointé de
d'appliquer la loi la loi existe mais
elle n'est pas appliquée la difficulté
d'accompagner les enfants qui ont des
smartphones de plus en plus jeunes et
donc l'impossibilité c'est évident pour
les parents de contrôler la ce qu'ils
font à longueur de journée avec ses
smartphones
et puis l'éducation à la sexualité avec
finalement une génération vous dites qui
a été élevé avec ces outils là et qui
s'est auto forme et auto protégés et qui
a développé des outils pour ce pour se
mettre à l'abri des violences qui qui
sont sur ces sites et ces grandes
grandes grands opérateurs du porno donc
je vais peut-être passer la parole pour
éviter de monopoliser la parole à deux
rapporteurs qui sont connectés je crois
qu alexandre à bordeaux fantin n'a pas
pu se connecter immédiatement avec nous
mais j'ai à mes côtés laurence cohen qui
a peut-être des questions à vous poser à
la fois sur ce que vous venez de venir
et sur les pistes qui pourraient être
travaillé sur la protection des mineurs
notamment puisque c'est le sujet aussi
qui nous occupait cet après midi merci à
vous et je cède la parole immédiatement
laurence cohen et peut-être ensuite
laurence rossignol qui en visio avec
nous depuis le palais
oui merci beaucoup madame pour votre
présentation
effectivement je pense que vous l'avez
dit dès le départ c'est à dire que vous
n'êtes pas là au nom d'une morale
quelconque mais voilà vous faites un
travail auprès d'un certain nombre de
jeunes d'élèves et
qui peut permettre de mieux les armer
par rapport aux images qu'il peut voir
moi c'est peut-être là dessus que que
j'aimerais avoir un
10 ans un dialogue avec vous c'est que
vous parlez beaucoup de la conscience de
ces jeunes mais en même temps on voit
quand même et on a eu un certain nombre
d'auditions il ya aussi des études on
voit que les images auxquelles ils
peuvent être exposés
sont d'une telle violence que c'est une
forme d'agression et effectivement ils
ont l'impression que pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux que c'est ça la
réalité des rapports qu'on doit avoir
entre entre entre jeunes et des rapports
sexuels et donc essayer de reproduire
les mêmes choses et là on sait on voit
que ce sont des rapports pour beaucoup
de domination et en général de
domination des garçons sur sur les
filles donc moi je suis
attentive à cet aspect là des choses en
terme de prévention en fait c'est à dire
comment est ce que à la fois on
développe une éducation réel à la
sexualité parce que pardonnez moi je
vais être direct mais vraiment l'école
ne peut pas ne veut pas jouer ce rôle là
en tout cas c'est totalement insuffisant
et plutôt à mon sens inadaptée
et donc comment on remet on ré on remet
les choses un peu en ordre pour qu'il y
ait un vrai travail d'éducation et
commet également on développe l'esprit
critique parce que je pense qu on est
dans un sens un siècle des images on est
assailli d'image de toutes parts et donc
il faut pouvoir avoir un esprit critique
qui décodent les choses comment est-ce
que donc ces deux aspects c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
c'est sûr
effectivement les grandes
multinationales
du sexe qui existe quand même depuis un
moment et qui se développe et qui ne
sont pas inquiétés par les mesures qui
peuvent être prises
on a été plusieurs lors d'auditions
précédente à nous interroger sur le fait
que quand on veut
sécuriser
sécuriser des opérations et notamment
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
opération bancaire on a des moyens sous
forme de verrouillage carte bleue etc
etc et la question qui est posée c'est
justement pour protéger les enfants
mineurs comment est ce qu'on peut faire
en sorte qu'il suffit pas de répondre
oui non je suis je suis je suis majeur
mais qu'il y ait vraiment un
comme on dirige un dispositif de
sécurité qui permettent de s'assurer que
la personne qui qui est face à l'écran
est vraiment mineur donc est ce que là
dessus vous avez vous avez des pistes à
nous à nous proposer donc voilà les deux
les deux styles de question que
j'aimerais vous poser et afin d'avoir un
dialogue avec vous je vous remercie
merci peut-être vous laisser répondre à
ses premières questions de la
rapporteure laurence cohen et puis
ensuite je passerai la parole à laurence
rossignol
entendu
concernant votre votre première question
qui concerne donc les actions de
prévention
le luxe c'est le temps en fait c'est le
temps alors effectivement gars
moi j'ai discuté avec beaucoup de chefs
d'établissement alors c'était passé son
département de la charente donc j'ai pas
de vision d'ensemble de tous les ai tous
les établissements scolaires de france
et de navarre j'ai pas dessus pas cette
vision là je sais qu'il ya des
disparités d'un établissement à l'autre
moi j'étais je suis intervenu dans des
établissements qui étaient nés des des
établissements d'élite ni deux ni non
plus vraiment dans les quartiers
populaires pour être clair
néanmoins ce que ce que j'ai pu observer
c'est donc cette hyper lucidité de de
ces adolescents là et ces adolescentes
et je crois beaucoup à
je crois qu'il faut les amener à
produire leurs propres discours et leurs
propos réflexion et qui a vraiment que
comme ça qu'on les fait avancer le
problème c'est que pour faire ça il faut
du temps c'est à dire que souvent et ça
c'est ce que vous diront tous les
intervenants et toutes les intervenantes
quand il arrive dans un été dans un
établissement faire leurs deux heures
déjà deux heures c'est rien c est quand
ils arrivent pour faire leurs deux
heures ils arrivent en intervention
pompiers a pesté les interventions
pompiers c'est à dire il ya eu un
problème dans l'établissement une
agression sexuelle une vidéo d'une jeune
fille qui a circulé
donc de situation de revenge porn pour
autre chose ou plus grave ou moins
graves
mais en général c'est comme ça qui est à
ce moment là qu'ils demandent au
planning familial où ça nous tenterons
centre d'information des droits des
femmes d'intervenir par exemple dans ce
genre de ce contexte la roma s'est pas
dans ce contexte là qui est pas un
contexte apaisé qu'on peut les amener à
réfléchir à décrypter les images franchi
décrypter les images ne pas dire leur
acheter des images en ces images là ils
ont déjà vu il n'y a pas besoin de
dépassement d re regarder avec eux en
toute façon on n'a pas le 3 pitre sur la
loi l'interdît et puis et puis il en est
hors de question mais d amener à à
produire leurs compos dix courses et les
amener à réfléchir par eux mêmes ce
qu'encore une fois tous les discours de
prévention assez classique la sécu
kabyle en exil sont pas sensibles et ça
marche pas ça marche pas et c'est
compliqué en plus de leur dire mais tu
sais le porno c'est pas là c'est pas du
vrai sexe ou c'est pas la réalité parce
que qu'est ce qu'ils en savent de ce que
c'est que le vrai sexe et la réalité en
fait quand ils ont 13 14 15 ans en fait
le ca veut pas dire qu'ils n'ont pas
déjà eu eux mêmes des expériences mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que ce qu'est
ce que ça veut dire cette notion de vrai
sexe barre si c'est dur et sexe
finalement ce qu'ils voient à l'écran et
en plus c'est d'autant plus vrai c'est
ce que maintenant c'est devenu des
normes pour plein de gens écouter pour
des luttes
donc dire produisent eux mêmes ce avec
quoi ils ont grandi ou ce qu'ils ont vu
sur l'écran donc je crois beaucoup à ça
le problème c'est que ça pour faire ça
il faut il faut du temps il faut tomber
dans des établissements où on nous fait
confiance j'ai une principale de collège
qui m'a expliqué que l entre la sécurité
routière des ateliers de tri de
recyclage etc il était déjà qu'on en
demandait beaucoup à l'école finalement
on en demande est peut-être trop et que
elle même elle me disait qu'elle avait
du mal à mettre en place tout ça il ya
eu aussi la peur qui n'est pas toujours
justifiée par ailleurs l'apport de la
réaction des parents il ya toujours un
peu ce trauma de
l'abaisser d'égalité ou maintenant
quatre chefs d'établissement qui se
disent oh là mondiaux et qu'est-ce qui
se passe aussi tout à coup il ya une
levée de boucliers des par des parents
alors qu'en réalité les parents pour
avoir aussi fait pas mal de café des
parents d'élèves a participé à pas mal
de réunions cpe c'est déjà de la fcpe
etc les parents peuvent ils sont plutôt
désireux de ça ils sont tellement
débordés dépassés par la situation
qu'ils ont envie justement qui est des
intervenants ou des intervenants
professionnels
qui prennent qui prennent ça en charge
parce qu'eux mêmes ils sont perdus déjà
ils sont parfois complètement déboussolé
face aux nouveaux outils numériques ils
sont pas forcément au courant de ce à
quoi ont axé leurs gamins tik tok
snapshot c'est quoi ce truc fin voilà
donc ils ont ils ont très mauvaise
connaissance de ses soutes de ces outils
là
et puis et puis en plus atout charme
intime sa touche ici à leurs propres
tabous donc on est vraiment deux
délégués donc donc bien sûr bien sûr
qu'il faudrait mettre toutes ses séances
en place et plus déjà ces deux heures
sont même pas mise en place des heures
obligatoires en théorie ne sont même pas
mis en place mais ce qu'il faudrait
c'est beaucoup plus moi j'ai eu la
chance de suivre deux des groupes
parfois il ya eu en trop dans un lycée
un groupe que j'ai pu suivre tous les
mercredis après midi on faisait
d'écriture scénaristique et voilà et ça
c'est pas un luxe et là on le voit des
résultats mais c'est pas une
intervention pompiers en catastrophe de
deux heures pour dire bon vous savez
faire circuler une vidéo c'est pas enfin
je pense qu'il faut il faut quand même
plus plus que ça mais quand c'est bien
année ils en ont envie en fait ce qu'ils
veulent ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est un
espace de parole c'est quand même ça qui
est souvent revenu de la part des jeunes
garçons comme des jeunes filles disent
on voudrait un espace de parole on
voudrait parler eux ils veulent pas
écouter ils veulent pas qu'on leur fasse
la leçon ils veulent juste pouvoir
s'exprimer dans un cadre
sécurisé self comme ils disent ça c'est
ce serait ma première ma première
réponse après concernant
les plateformes j'ai pas de solutions
techniques ont parlé des moyens de
paiement il s'est passé ça quand même
aux etats unis c'est à dire peut-être
que certainement vous l'avez vu passer
il y avait eu un article dans le new
york times ce qui s'appelait children of
pornhub il ya une cinquantaine de
plaintes aux états unis
contre eux pornhub de femmes jeunes
femmes qui se sont retournés contre leur
gré sur ces sites là et il me semble
quand la plupart d'entre elles étaient
mineures au moment des faits
donc on s'est rendu compte que la
modération sur ce site là était
catastrophique qu'il y avait des images
voilà que qu'il y avait des images avec
des gens des personnes à l'écran qui ne
consentait absolument pas pas parfois
pas forcément à l'acte en lui même un
mais que papa forcément aux rapports
mais qu'il n'avait pas donné leur
consentement pour être affichée comme ça
sur sur des sites pornographiques par
leurs actes petit ami ou parent je ne
sais quel le harceleur donc donc il ya
il ya ça il a toutes ces plaintes ne
sont au courant en cours aux états unis
et il ya eu un moment de janvier à cette
histoire de moyens de paiement il ya eu
visa mastercard je ne sais pas où ça en
est maman mais il ya eu visa master
league un moment magnifique et donc la
multinationale canadienne qui détient or
neuf du port les plans d'autres sites
il ya eu un moment où je sais pas si
c'est toujours le cas mais puissent à
mastercard ils ont décidé de deux roues
toute parole à tous les moyens de
paiement visa et mastercard était hs sur
sur ces sites là donc voilà est-ce que
c'est toujours le cas ou pas mais en
tout cas effectivement taper là où ça
fait mal ces diamants porte monnaie ça
peut être ça peut être une stratégie
intéressante en ce moment mais
j'ai pas vraiment j'ai pas vraiment de
solution à proposer si ce n'est que je
suis quand même étonné qu' il n'y ait
pas de tous les pays européens ne soient
n'accordent pas leurs violons sur cette
question en fait c'est à dire chacun
dans son coin déplore la même chose
chacun envisage
de taper du poing sur la table du faso
blaise compaoré à mon avis pas forcément
efficace mais la réalité c'est que
chaque pays pris de façon individuelle
n'a aucun poids face et ce site là et
que et que le seul moyen de mettre en
place des choses sensées cohérente ce
serait quand même d'accorder nos violons
partout sur l'ensemble de l'europe quoi
en fait j'ai l'impression que c'est ça
un niveau européen que ça devrait se
passer mais après bon voila moi c'est
pas mon métier donc donc que je suis pas
vraiment en mesure d'apporter des
solutions je peux juste vous rapporter
ce que ce que je vois et ce que je
constate qu'on puisse peut-être une
précision si vous le permettez madame
concernant visa mastercard ce que vous
venez d'évoquer en est ce que c'est le
fait que avec la visa mastercard il
était impossible d'acheter des contenus
ou c'est que dans quel sens ça
fonctionnait en fait est ce que à partir
du moment où vous aviez une visa
mastercard vous ne pouviez pas acheter
des contenus bon même si cette
discussion en réalité elle va voir
quelle que soit votre réponse les
contenus ils sont gratuits bien souvent
donc mais quelques est comment ça
fonctionnait ce que vous pouvez juste
détaillé parce qu'avec ma collègue
laurence que cohen rapporteur on n'a pas
très bien compris ce à quoi vous faisiez
référence oui c'est pas évident c'est à
dire sur ces sites là avec ces
multinationales détiennent énormément si
donc les gros combinés à cornaux qui
sont ces gosses ne forme mais qui
peuvent renvoyer vers du contenu payant
par exemple sur port neuf je sais pas si
ça existe encore il y avait une section
modèle hub
qui à mon avis a été mise en péril
justement par part
cette histoire de visa mastercard donc
il ya en gros 1,6 de lifecam ou de
performeurs qui vendent des faits qui
mettent en ligne des vidéos payantes et
ça passe donc ça passe par ces sites là
c'est à dire en clair cette grosse
plateforme la de contenu gratuit est
d'ailleurs souvent bien trop souvent
piratées
renvoient vers des contenus payants ou
là il faut sortir sa carte bleue et
c'est là en fait où ça fait mal
maintenant c'est pas leur seul modèle
économique leur modèle économique
principal c'est générer des millions des
milliards de clics et de vendre de
l'espace publicitaire c'est à dire vous
avez déjà certainement remarqué si vous
allez sur ses plates formes là vous
allez avoir toutes les vidéos dans des
petites cases pressé par catégorie et
serra est souvent sur le côté vous allez
avoir une publicité pour des choses
extrêmement utile du genre des gélules
pour augmenter la quantité de sperme ce
genre de choses 3 donc le goût des sites
de lifecam ce genre de choses
donc ils vendent de de l'espace
publicitaire donc en fait c'est sûr ils
ont quand même un modèle une partie de
leur modèle économique qui est payant
mais on sait on suppose quand on regarde
les montages de ces multinationales là
et qu'on voit qu'ils sont qu'ils ont
plein d'un ex à chypre panama
l'irlande le luxembourg et cetera
on comprend quand même qu'il ya une
circulation de l'argent qui n'est pas
net net on sait pas exactement pourquoi
ni comment ça fonctionne mais on voit
quand même que ça fait partie de leur
modèle économique
de cette circulation je vous remercie de
ces précisions la dame et je vais passer
la parole à notre collègue et rapporteur
laurence rossignol derrière l'écran
bonjour jean collègues de bonjour
je suis contente de vous retrouver dans
cette vision et je comprends votre
découragement
des années pour qu'on parle de ça y
compris effectivement à part peut-être
une plus grande
lité d'une partie de l'opinion ou les
décideurs publics à ces sujets
aucune solution n'a réellement été mise
en oeuvre du nom aucune solution
efficace a réellement été les heures je
voulais faire du genre de type de
remarque d'abord sur les questions
d'éducation et le travail que vous avez
menées en charente
vous avez raison de dire que ça demande
beaucoup de temps ce qui est d'ailleurs
la limite de la dupliquer bilité de ce
type de travail ça demande du temps ça
demande des intervenantes fort mais
c'est pas n'importe comment c'est papa
de paix relancées par les contraceptions
à des jeunes c'est forcément leur parler
aussi finement que vous la question
qu'elle apprend enfin depuis des
cottages et des protections contre les
vidéos pornos et je suis toujours en
hadjel soins des batteries collègues je
trouve perplexe sur notre capacité
collective
à
déployer ce type de formation d'autant
que la conviction c'est un peu comme
pour les affaires de cyber harcèlement
quelque chose égale par ailleurs c'est
pas de la même chose mais dans les
établissements scolaires ou qui sont
très engagés sur la lutte contre le
cyber harcèlement c'est une mobilisation
de toute l'équipe éducative et c'est une
mobilisation au long cours c'est pas
simplement une
shot ou comme foot c'est tout à l'heure
où une intervention pompiers donc c'est
une grosse mobilisation et je comprends
ce besoin de d'éducation et en même
temps une partie de moi-même peut pas
s'empêcher d'être un peu perplexe quand
même devant l'idée que pour faire face
avec des industrie très lucrative très
lucrative que sont l'industrie
pornographique et aussi les fournisseurs
d'accès parce qu'il ya un petit sujet
fournisseurs d'accès également
son on est obligé de déployer des moyens
publics
de l'argent public pour que ces
industries puisse continuer de faire
leur business dans les mêmes conditions
et ce soit nous qui devions nous
protéger mais aucun moment qu'on puisse
réellement en limiter n'ont pas l'impact
mais simplement l'existence et la
diffusion jeu tout cas quelque chose qui
est assez
déséquilibré plus faire cette remarque
cela parce que je je je pense que tu
m'en suis aujourd'hui et celle de mes
questions il ya un consensus pour dire
que l'exposition précoce aux images
pornographiques et pas très bonne pour
les enfants mais si vous pensez que
l'industrie pornographique ni
préjudiciable aux jeunes qu'aux enfants
est ce que ce n'est pas aussi
préjudiciable aux adultes avec toutes
les évolutions que vous signez que vous
avez souligné dans notre ration
particulier de ce que sont les méthodes
et pratiques de tournage dans le
traitement des actrices les acteurs et
puis ici les contenus qui ont changé et
l'industrie pornographique et c'est
peut-être moralistes de poser la
question mais répandue peu importe est
ce que l'industrie pornographique a pas
une une diffusion une toxicité peine
dangerosité qui va au delà de des
enfants dans la mesure où elle et par
elle et les vidéos sont a conduit
raciste sexiste une unité anti fob et on
trouve toute la gamme des infractions
pénales qui sont diffusés et qui ne
concerne pas que tous les délits mineurs
et puis aussi du point de vue des
l'industrie pornographique alors on a
reçu l'autre jour d ancienne actrice
devenue réalisatrice et productrice donc
leur point de vue dans cette actrice est
un peu fait que maintenant il est pressé
productrice s'est pas simplement qu'un
point de vue de danser l'actrice qui
demandent en fait régulation inspection
du travail le syndicat avant que toute
la profession s'organise et
je me demande jusqu'à quel point c'était
la société de s'adapter à une
une industrie qui est de plus en plus
violentes et dans ses formes de travail
de l'activité et dans les images qu'elle
montre
merci chers collègues je vous laisse
répondre aux fidji
il ya plusieurs questions la première
c'est que c'est un peu comme si on se
disait est ce que c'est à nous de
financiers les actions de prévention
contre contre la drogue alors qu'en fait
ce qu'il faudrait faire ça arrêter la
drogue moi par exemple je pense que je
pense que oui je comprends ce que vous
dites en disant c'est pas l'argent
public l'argent public il doit être
mobilisés pour réparer les dégâts et
d'un autre côté mme ainsi un petit peu
quand même en fait mais au vide et la
drogue c'est illégal la drogue illégale
las le trafic de drogue il est illégal
la création et la diffusion d'image
pornographique ne l'est pas
women
l'hyperaccessibilité
auprès des mineurs les aides est illégal
c'est à dire c'est ce type là sont pas
des langues dans les clous la légalité
des sites dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure ils sont pas dans les coûts de
la légalité et c'est bien ça tombe bien
ça le problème c'est bien ces sites là
qui sont responsables de la consommation
la quasi totalité de la consommation de
porno par les mineurs les mineurs ils
vont pas regarder le film porno du
samedi soir sur canal je n'aime pas ça
existe encore à mon bref c'est pas assez
pas là qu'ils vont avoir accès ou au
porno s'ils vont avoir accès directement
sur leur portable avec des sites qui
jouent pas le jeu de la légalité qui
déjà au niveau de leurs modèles
économiques sont puisque obscures mais
qui en plus ne jouent pas le jeu de la
légalité est ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
aussi savoir c'est que
il ya aussi beaucoup de gens qui font
partie où on fait partie en tout cas au
moment où j'étais pendant classique il
faisait partie de cette industrie qui je
pense des acteurs des actrices qui ont
eux mêmes des enfants par ailleurs et
puis étaient opposés qui était en guerre
contre ces sites là et pas seulement
parce que ces sites là venait mettre à
mal leur leur activité et que ça venait
taper dans leur portefeuille ce n'était
pas ça dans la porte monnaie c'était pas
ça qui était pas pour ça qu'ils que qui
partez en croisière pour ses sites
classés qu'eux ils étaient estomaqués de
voir que ces six cas qui ne sont pas
détenues par des gens du il faut bien
savoir ce sont des gens qui sont
spécialisés dans la circulation de
l'argent sont pas des producteurs de
porno qui détiennent ces sites là
donc il faut aussi bien savoir que dans
cette industrie là il y a des gens qui
soient des acteurs ou des anciennes
actrices ou que sage qui s'y opposent en
scène et qui sont absolument pas
d'accord avec le fait que ces sites à
puce est accessible comme ça sans aucune
régulation auprès d'un public d'un
public mineur ça c'est quand même
important de de préciser et
ce n'est pas un c'est pas un secret on
suit réglementariste je ne crois pas
interdiction pure et dure aussi parce
que j'ai vu c'est devant
25 maintenant dernières années évoluer
23 dernières années évoluer cette
industrie mais si aujourd'hui je la
regarde vraiment de très loin et qui est
encore posé plus vraiment de contacts
mais je la regarde quand même évolué et
ce que je constate c'est que le fait
justement qu'il n'est plus de garde-fous
qui n'est plus tout ça a été la porte
ouverte au grand n'importe quoi et à la
violence je vais donner un exemple
début des années 2000 aucun des années
à la télévision pour diffuser du contenu
pendant l'été les gens puisque c'était
quand même ça aussi on revient en
arrière un pas en arrière c'était même
le film porno du samedi soir qui était
la principale source de profits y avait
de plus de 2 millions personnes comme
tous les premiers samedis du mois puis
regardez celle de kana donc c'était
vraiment énorme
pour être diffusée à la télévision il
fallait qu'ils soient diffusés après
minuit seulement sur les chaînes qui
avaient l'autorisation en avec un
système de double cryptage qui a été mis
en place si je ne m'abuse l'air 2002
enfin voilà il y avait un certain nombre
de règles à respecter des règles et
parfois était même un peu absurde mais
il fallait mais des choses qui étaient
censés comme par exemple l'obligation du
préservatif l'interdiction de la
violence a pris avait des choses très
détaillée du genre ne pas mettre en
scène des rapports tarifés à l'écran ne
pas mettre en scène pas de mises
ensemble de viols etc pas de
strangulation pas de pas de gifles pas
de claques donc
on peut penser ce qu'on veut de ça et on
peut dire que ces films où il n'était
pas bien malins effectivement ils
n'étaient pas forcément toujours très
glorieux est-ce qu'ils étaient tous
méchants j'en sais rien je prends pas il
était peut-être bête n'est pas méchant
c'est rien mais en tout cas il y avait
des règles ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il y avait des règles et ce que je
constate quand même ces salles avantage
d'être vieille maintenant c'est que je
recule cette vision ressenti plus de 20
ans c'est que c'est que moins il ya deux
règles et plus plus est partie vraiment
à vau l'eau et c'est là que que les
problèmes ont commencé à se poser c'est
à partir du moment où les producteurs de
contenus n'ont plus l'obligation de se
plier à toute cette réglementation en
fait c'est à partir du moment parce que
évidemment que avant quand là pour
donner un exemple vraiment très précis
pendant très longtemps la france a été
un des seuls pays à tourner avec
préservatif
les italiens les allemands les
américains des hongrois les tchèques
tourner et ont toujours d'ailleurs sans
préservatif la france faisait office
d'exception pourquoi pas parce qu'en
france on était plus conscientisés que
les autres sur les questions de diester
c'est uniquement parce que canal+
imposer le préservatif pour sa diffusion
et canal+ à l'époque étant un des
principal diffuseur mais tout le monde
se plier à cette règle
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de règles
seront peu diffusé à peu près tout et
n'importe quoi on peut se mettre des
gifles sans problème sur des sites
pornos qui sont sur internet donc vu
qu'il n'ya plus de réglementation et ben
finalement ils vont au maximum du
maximum il repousse il repousse toutes
les limites c'est dans ce sens là où moi
je fais quand même pour une
réglementation alors quel type de
réglementation j'en sais rien parce
qu'encore une fois le métier a évolué je
suis plus dedans donc je sais pas ce
qu'il faut faire mais il me semble dans
tous les cas que la réglementation sera
toujours mieux que
que je vais redire une activité qui de
fait va continuer à exister et en
particulier dans les pays du genre
hongrie et république tchèque ça c'est
sûr et si c'est pas et même si demain la
hongrie disais bon maintenant ça suffit
on arrête chez on arrête ça qu'est ce
que ça va faire savez ce sa place à
partir sur le sur un an au pays fin
ou alors surtout comme ça s'est passé
aux états unis avaya quelle étape qui
est interdit finalement on va bouger
dans l'état voisin enfin c'est sans fin
en fait est là encore avec des contenus
qui sont parfois pour ou pas tolérable
qu'on n'arrivera pas à bloquer parce
qu'on aura en plus des fournisseurs
d'accès si en ski romand abbaoui mais
non on n'est pas tout et chaud pour me
faire et puis des vidéos qui seront
référencés par google aussi parce que
tout à l'heure on faisait un dossier
fournisseurs d'accès mais un dossier
google aussi amusant quand même du
référencement il ya là aussi les formes
et dans ceux ci
merci beaucoup madame est ce que
laurence voulait réagir par rapport à la
réponse qui lui a été donnée ou où
c'était ok bah oui parce que je trouve
intéressant ce que vous dites sur le
fait il ya il ya un âge un agent siècle
qui était une pendule canal où il est en
fait les diffusion des films
pornographiques se faisait dans deux
types de par deux types de moyens il y
avait soit les salles de cinéma porno
soit le film porno de samedi soir sur
canal avec toutes les règles que vous
venez de d'indiquer et qui effectivement
en fait en limitait se conclut
aujourd'hui de tous mais considérés
comme étant les excès enfin où les
dérives du porno mais quand on n'y a
plus de règle s'est passé pas plus drive
c'est pas parce que on en a abandonné
les règles il n'y a plus de règle parce
que il n'ya on ne sait plus comment on
ne sait pas comment appliquer ces ied
aujourd'hui sur des modes de diffusion
qui échappe totalement ce
qui nous échappe totalement en fait
c'est facile de dire à canal voilà les
dires à canal+ voilà les les règles qui
sont cave est respectée pour la
diffusion de ses films porno c'est une
chose mais aujourd'hui lutter mode de
diffusion où viennent de partout son
dessin vendent partout la question c'est
que même si on met de la règle comment
on fait respecter des règles sur dans
ses modes de diffusion là avec des films
sont tournés
dans les pays de l'est par exemple et
qui sont diffusées
sur des plateformes qui n'obéissent à
aucune règle pas davantage à celle de la
note d'une l'accès des mineurs que à
celle de la réglementation des contenus
donc c'est pas comme tu sais pas comment
va renoncer aux règles c'est qu'il n'y a
plus d' espaces des règles est ce que je
disais pas est-ce que je vous pose la
question d'ailleurs
sur ces contenus sont diffusées sur des
sites qui
respecte néanmoins certaines règles mais
qui ne sont pas celles de la loi
française c'est à dire par exemple ces
sites là tout comme youtube a d'ailleurs
au delà du porno où sont basées sur
la loi de 98 98 ces jeux français tech
lim fans qui étaient au pouvoir qui est
le 10ème s'il est en fait qu on appelle
le deuxième signé et c'est ce qui fait
que toutes les plateformes de partage de
contenus sont nés c'est ce qui fait par
exemple que n'importe qui peuplent haut
d une vidéo sur youtube
prétendre avoir les droits et elle
devait être engraissée ce qui s'est
passé pour ses plateformes là bon c'est
plate forme
en fait elle est
à chaque fois qu'on essaie dé mettre en
difficulté elle sortait loi américaine
en fait c'est ça qui est compliqué c'est
c'est aussi pour 70 à l'heure je disais
il faudrait quand même qu'on accord nos
violons sur l'ensemble de l'europe
c'est-à-dire s'il n'y avait pas une
multiplicité de réglementation et de loi
chacun faisant son miel de son côté je
pense que ce serait peut-être plus
facile à imposer ça que face à ces sites
là qui à chaque fois dit ça mais
regardez nous on respecte la loi
américaine quoi je sais pas si je suis
clair dans mon explication mais moi j'ai
quand même l'impression que il ya il ya
un e à ce niveau là et je ne crois pas
qu'il faille se concentrer qui failli
taper j'irai sur des petits c'est pas si
sert à rien de 2 par exemple d'interdire
les tournages en france je veux dire ça
par exemple sera un homme sincère ça
sert à rien du tout à la rigueur et goût
mais qu'ils aient lieu là et qu'on les
ait sous contrôle et qu'on sache ce qui
s'y passe plutôt que que que les
interdire enfin j'en sais rien mais
franchement à part en tout cas je pense
que c'est là que ça de ces la porte à la
clandestinité
et au pire quoi mais
je peut que renvoyer vers ça c'est à
dire à moi j'ai quand même l'impression
qu'il faudrait que en europe on accorde
aux jumeaux je suis persuadé que que
c'est là que ça va se ça va se jouer
comme ça ils ne pourront plus nous
répondre bah on respecte la loi
américaine
écoutez
merci beaucoup pour ces éléments de
réponse et c'est vrai que vous avez déjà
fait un long travail pendant ses années
de documentation de l'évolution de la
pornographie on l'a vu à travers vos
productions vos témoignages la
pornographie de 2022 n'a rien à voir
avec la pornographie qu'on a pu
connaître auparavant les sites
évidemment et les les plateformes ont
une responsabilité
comment réussira à faire appliquer la
loi notamment la non d'exposition des
mineurs à ces images pornographiques on
peut re quand même se poser la question
lorsqu'on arrive à supprimer des contres
des réseaux sociaux certaines
personnalités on peut peut-être imaginer
qu'on peut réussir à fermer plus
rapidement des sites pornographiques qui
diffusent des images qui sont l'apologie
du racisme de la pédocriminalité des
violences faites aux femmes donc la
question se pose quand même parce qu' il
existe des algorithmes pour moi que ça
et j'imagine qu'on pourrait imaginer
produire à notre époque en 2022 des
algorithmes qui permettrait de repérer
en temps réel ses images sur ces
plateformes et ces sites la difficulté
probablement liée à la lutte contre ces
cette pornographie qui génère des
milliards de dollars c'est justement la
puissance qu'elle dégage financières et
les revenus qu'elle dégage donc on a
peut-être des pistes à
étudier par rapport à toutes ces
annonces publicitaires qui font vivre
aussi et qui participe au développement
de cette industrie donc certaines pistes
peut-être s'offre à nous sur l'éducation
à la sexualité nous à la délégation aux
droits des femmes on est mobilisé depuis
plusieurs années sur cette nonne
éducation à la sexualité en réalité et
je vous rejoins à 100% bien souvent les
les interventions sont des interventions
en réaction à hénon pas une véritable
éducation à la sexualité je trouve très
intéressant ce que vous avez dit aussi
sur la proche qu'on doit avoir par
rapport à la pornographie et les mineurs
ça rejoint d'ailleurs ce qu'avait dit la
procureure chant renault qui a travaillé
missionné par le gouvernement sur la
prostitution c'est à dire qu'on ne doit
aussi s'adresser à ces adolescents à ces
jeunes en construction non pas avec une
optique moralisatrice mais bien entendu
on doit comprendre eux leur vision et et
pouvoir s'adapter et adapter notre
accompagnement de ces jeunes pour
essayer de lorsqu'ils sont très jeunes
de les mettre en garde contre les
dangers de ces expositions et ensuite de
peut-être travailler avec eux pour voir
comment mieux lutter contre cette
exposition des jeunes donc je vous
remercie madame pour ces précisions pour
le travail que vous menez depuis
plusieurs années pour alerter j'espère
que les travaux que nous allons mener
avec les trois rapporteurs vont réussir
à faire des propositions des
propositions qui pourront être
applicable il ya peut-être un travail
aussi a amené avec on sait aujourd'hui
par exemple il ya un index de l'égalité
l'index de légalité bien lorsque des
jeunes rentrent dans les entreprises ça
peut être un critère pour pour avoir
envie d'aller travailler parce que les
jeunes
accordent une importance à toutes ces
notions d'égalité par exemple donc est
ce qu'il est possible qu'on travaille
nous aussi pour flécher et bien des
plates formes d'aidés google
des outils qui permettront d'identifier
les personnes qui ne respectent pas la
réglementation en vigueur lorsque vous
parlez de l'europe bien entendu l'europe
et pour avoir regardé votre vos travaux
ce week-end
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on voit les
conditions de travail de ces acteurs de
ces actrices on a
on ne peut pas se limiter au territoire
national il faut une véritable
conscience collective et des
propositions à l'échelle de l'europe
parce que les plateformes elle ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières donc merci
sincèrement pour avoir consacré ce temps
à la délégation et nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux avec les trois
rapporteurs et
nous nous espérons faire des
propositions concrètes efficaces pour
toutes les problématiques qui ont été
évoqués au cours de cette émission je
vous remercie madame
merci